he's uh colin morikawa and uh had a
chance to talk to him
yesterday and he's uh had quite a
24-hour period there after winning the
pga championship and i
asked him how did he celebrate sunday
night after winning the pga championship
uh you know we just had some drinks
after the round at the course
um i really didn't sleep i had
in and out this couple hours ago and i
just
absolutely tore through a couple burgers
i'm living off a lot of adrenaline right
now i'll tell you that when did you
realize
that you could win this thing um
seriously after the end of saturday um
even before saturday's round you know i
felt like if i had a good round
i could really make a charge um and
being on that leading spot
being a couple behind starting sunday i
thought you know
shoot it's anyone's chance you know
after i looked at the leaderboard on 12
it was a
nice large party of us at 10 under um
so you just kind of had to to take it in
and
tell yourself you know this is your time
you're not going to get
you know an opportunity like this to
really separate yourself
um and i just had to take any
opportunity i got
it's one thing to play the course it's
another thing to play it when it's
souped up pga standard wise so you
played it before
but the biggest difference between when
you played it before is an amateur to
playing it for a pga championship was
what
oh i mean everything it was a completely
different course
other than the layout of what it looks
like you know visually
you talk about the t's being all the way
back some of the holes i had never
played all the way back from those tees
the rough was
way longer than i've ever seen it so
fairways were that much more important
pins were way tougher so i think from t
to green everything was just
a completely different course so even
though i knew it i had to come out and
be prepared and not get lazy with all my
prep work you know monday through
wednesday or tuesday one day really
i know that people are going to focus on
16 but i went back and i
i think you had a par save very early
maybe first hole and then you got to
chip in as well
and i you know you just start to look at
these pieces it's a jigsaw
and you put them all together and i know
that you hit sick you know that
shot on 16 will be talked about for
decades but
it was the other ones that kind of fill
in the gray area there
that if you don't have those then 16
might not matter
absolutely and you hit it spot on the
par putt at one and the part but at six
that were you know roughly
25 30 feet um saved my round
if i started making bogey on hole one
while everyone else is making birdies
um i already kicked myself in the in the
foot and then you know i'm already one
step behind if not two
and i would have had to do that much
more work to catch up you know so those
par saves were huge to keep the momentum
going
um obviously after one but you know on
six i was already two under
and going into holes eight nine those
are some of the toughest holes on the
course so you just want to try and get
out there with bar
um so you know yes 16
is going to be one of the most memorable
drives i think the putt
was almost more important than the drive
um
yes you know i had to get my drive there
but i had to make that putt the punt had
to go in
uh or else those last two holes could
have been a little different what did
the ball feel like when it left
your driver on 16. uh
there's nothing to ex describe it you
know it just felt right
and i i think that's what all golfers
whether you know they've played golf or
not
they know when they hit that one really
good shot
that that's what it's like um and i hit
it exactly how i wanted all my caddy and
i were praying for was a good bounce
and uh you know you just gotta have luck
on your side and thankfully i did
and from that point on you know we
weren't even paying attention to where
the ball was rolling we just knew it was
on the green
everybody talked about the bombers and
they were going to take advantage of
that golf course and then i kept
thinking
i didn't i remember watching you at cal
in the ncaa tournament and i didn't
remember you hit it
you know extraordinarily long and then i
went back and i said
your average is around 290 something i
think
so the that was a perfect hole for your
driver
like you didn't have to amp it up you
didn't have to dial it back down it was
like if i hit a 290 or 292
i'm pretty good here yeah it was it was
made for me
it was made for you know the cold
weather the 295 hitters
um you know i played with cameron champ
and he's definitely one of the longest
hitters on tour
and he's got to hit this little small
little slice um and i'm just you know
stepping up there and all i got to do is
hit a normal drive i don't have to do
anything special
um so those holes kind of fit my eye you
know the same thing 14 at beer field
same exact you know kind of distance
wise i just have to hit a normal driver
and i'm right there
um but you know i'm glad you said it
like that i'm not a long hitter
but i'm glad you didn't say i'm a short
hitter i think of myself
as just average
well if you do anything just average it
might be that colin everything else that
you're doing is is above average
and then you look around so there's no
fans at what point do you notice that
steph curry
is following you yeah no i'm a huge
sports fan
um so i i started seeing him on the
eighth green
i saw him on ninety and my caddy didn't
even recognize him you know i mean he
did but i pointed him out i'm pretty
observant
especially with no fans out there you
can kind of tell who is who even with
the hat and the mask on
um and steph was awesome you know they
had him come in the media center after
and asked me a question
um he's just an awesome dude and just an
amazing basketball player too obviously
but you had to tell him that you're not
a warriors fan absolutely not and you
know
i'm i'm an la guy at heart i love the
lakers i love the dodgers that's what i
breathe
um so you know our taylormade bag was a
giant
giant steam golf bag on the inside it
said
giants sweep and dynasty printed from
magazines when the you know the giants
had won
the world series um so you know i almost
don't want to touch the bag anymore i
don't want to look at it
it doesn't belong in my house um
and to be honest it won't be in my house
wait wait but who picked out the bag for
you
i know it's the bay area but you're a
dodger fan yeah
yeah you know i think the taylormade
guys just wanted to go with the theme of
of being in san francisco um so
you know i'm just saying the the u.s
open
is going to be in l.a i think at los
angeles country club in a few years
i better see something some blue and
white out there uh
if i don't i'm gonna be a little mad
when did you know you could play
with these guys oh man
um you know i played i was very
fortunate to
have a sponsors invite to you know now
corn ferry event when i was
heading into my sophomore year of
college between that summer of freshman
and sophomore year
um i had just made the cut on the number
i shot 63-63 i just saw a number
looking at all these little tweets and
instagram things um
to get into a playoff and that's when i
knew
what's so different about what i'm doing
compared to what these guys are doing
other than
you know the opportunities they're
getting i still wanted to finish up
college
you know i wanted to get my degree i got
my degree in four years at the high
school business an awesome program
very fortunate to to be a you know
graduate from there
but you know once that had happened and
seeing all my amateur career and looking
at the wins
i knew that i was meant to play golf and
i knew that this is what i wanted to do
and it was all about getting these
chances to play out there
who have you heard from since you won
that might surprise us
that might surprise you uh you know
there's a lot of golfers that have
texted me um i've gotten to know max
patretti pretty well
uh hockey player for the golden knights
he's been a pretty cool guy that i've
been able
to play with quite a few times over this
quarantine uh out here in las vegas
uh he he obviously reached out um
someone that
i never would have thought you know i
had met uh marco mira
you know two very different
you know age uh two very different time
periods of our golf but i was able to
meet him out here in vegas
um and we got to play a few times and
he's an amazing person because
great guy you know he lived through all
that through tiger's prime you know
tiger used him
as a learning experience and that's what
i'm trying to do with all these other
guys is just learn as much as i can
figure out what they're doing
what makes them great and kind of work
that into you know what's going to make
me great
what was that like the first time you go
up to tiger whether it's on the practice
range
uh introduce yourself you know you have
to have somebody introduce you
so you're nervous about doing that um
you know i was a little nervous but you
know i was very fortunate enough to uh
you know we've got the same agency um so
my mark steinberg helped me
you know introduce my myself to him okay
uh but the first time i played with him
he obviously went to stanford i went to
cal huge rivals
i still have a go bears uh garbage book
cover in my back left pocket so we tee
off at torrey pines first round on a
thursday
we both stripe ours down the middle i'm
walking right in front of him and he
looks at me
and he laughs and he just gives me a
little smirk he's like go bears
yeah right like oh my god like
but you know that's what makes i think
professional athletes
and just you know you put them on
another level of just being a normal
person
and to have them say that to me just
allowed me to just you know dive a
little deeper into being you know a
friend of tiger
not just a competitor that i see out on
the golf course you know
so uh that's one of the coolest stories
i have with him for sure
well it was great to watch and certainly
uh cool under fire there
and uh congratulations uh we appreciate
your time colin
thanks so much uh i appreciate you guys
having me out here today
that's your pga champ and he's only 23
years of
age got a chance to be a star